messieurs ne cherchez pas plus loin les
responsables du rallongement
inconsidérée des robes de nos compagnes
voici l'un d'eux karl lagarfeld visitant
ces derniers salons car le polyglotte et
apatrides créés chaque année près de
2000 vêtements ou accessoires féminins
cela signifie que les industriels de la
mode consommant voracement les idées car
laurent les siennes vous travaillez pour
qui pour eux
presqu'une vingtaine d'affaires
différentes de toutes sortes puisque je
fais aussi bien les vêtements et les
choses pour femmes pour ramer pour les
enfants et dans plusieurs pays et en
général je ne fais jamais deux fois la
même chose à dire je fais une collection
de robes cher une cohésion de rabot
marché des pull-overs des maillots de
bain mais je n'avais jamais même dans un
autre pays du foie la même chose parce
que le marché européen évidemment
beaucoup trop petit pour ça et ça serait
couperet parce que finalement on croit
par saison à une mode et paddy mode
femme à la forme je trouve encore un peu
trop gonflé derrière la réforme lever
tout ça face à des plats crème à la tête
il vaut mieux être carrément celui en
feutre que vous avez fait avec des
découpes c'est vous qui décidez tout en
principe est ce que vous êtes des spots
absolument pas en fait tout au suffrage
universel voyait bien je demande l'avis
de tout le monde
alors écoutez pas moi qui met les roms
quel intérêt d'avoir un styliste alors
si tout le monde a donné son avis ont
maquillé en fin de compte j'ai quand
même ce que je veux mais c'est qu'on
parle et les avis puis les robes nous a
fait à plusieurs ça t'es pas tout seul
tout ce que je demande à l'api qui
apporte il est bien des dents c'est
lassant c'est pas moi qui la mettra un
styliste et un homme d'affaires
également aux yankees ont terriblement
d'affaires moi j'ai pas très grande
affaire mais certains le sont
terriblement
est-ce que vous pouvez mettre en péril
une de ces maisons bien sûr bien sûr
vous pouvez bien sûr avec une très
mauvaise collection on peut très bien
mettre maison bord de la faillite mais
c'est alizé déjà non parlez pas de
malheur jusqu'ici que ça m'est pas
arrivé
l'argent beau c'est important pas plus
que pour les autres c'est à dire qui
paraît difficile de vivre sans gémir si
vous en gagnez 10 ans
beaucoup par rapport à quoi vous a été
une question de tout est relatif
d'accord ils ont aussi que je travaille
beaucoup aussi c'est à dire tout ça par
jour facilement samedi et dimanche j'ai
compris car vous avez débuté très jeune
dans le métier je crois oui j'ai
commencé à travailler en quittant
l'école de dire à 17 ans mais n'était
pas vraiment professionnel je suis
vraiment professionnel que finalement
que depuis six ans ça a très bien marché
tout de suite oui ou du côté matériel et
tout ça ça a marché
1 et l'âge de 17 ans à 20 ans gagné
combien par exemple pas à 510 francs à
20 ans oui et j'ai jamais fait du cully
[Musique]